A sperm whale can click at about
236 decibels. It's the loudest animal
on the planet. Sperm whales can hear
each other in the ocean from hundreds
even thousands of miles away. Some
researchers believe that they're able to keep in
contact with one another through these
clicks on other sides of the planet.
These clicks are so powerful in the
water that they can blow out your
eardrums easily. And they could actually
vibrate a human body to death. So when
you're diving with them it's a little
sketchy. What I'm going to show you now
is a video of some freedivers that I
ended up hanging out with. I wasn't with
them during this expedition, but I was
about six months later. We went on a trip
together and I had the same experience.
So clicks you're going to be
hearing are not coming from a boat. They
aren't coming from a camera. These are
the whales clicking these guys literally
from the inside out to see what they're
all about. And the clicks were so
powerful that one of these guys put out
his hand to stop a whale from running
into him. And his hand actually was
paralyzed for about four hours
afterwards. So he learned not to keep out
his hand in front of him when he was
diving. This is an emerging discipline of
research and it's pretty sketchy.
This is what it's like. I'm not going to
talk over this. We're going to play this
kind of loud, so you can really get an
experience of what this is all about.
So you're going to notice the whale
is going to flip on its belly. That's where
it collects those echoes, underneath its jaw.
They don't use ears under water.
We get a really good look at him right now.
Okay, so i know what you're thinking:
why the hell would anyone want to do that?
I know that was pretty loud for all
of us, but trust me in the water it's
like four million times louder.
Once you're hanging out with the whales for
a long time--this didn't happen to me, but
it happened to these guys, their bodies started
heating up from being pelleted with
all of that energy, after a while.
Again this is pretty sketchy stuff.
It's strange to do. But it's important to
note that these guys are fascinated by whales.
They don't necessarily want to
freedive with them this closely. But they have to
because it turns out the only
way to really study these animals up close
is by freediving with them. By
approaching them in your natural form
and interacting with them in that way.
SCUBA doesn't work, it's too loud.
Submarines don't work; same thing. Robots don't work;
they freak them out. But when you
freedive with them, this amazing paradigm shift occurs.
And they not only don't swim away,
but most of the time the whales will
turn around and welcome you into the pod.
Sometimes they orient themselves
vertically and do this very weird sort
of New Age thing around you.
As they're clicking. It's extremely intense.
So the next question you're probably
asking yourself is like why research
sperm whales? Well it turns out that those
clicks you heard they aren't just used
for echolocation. Sperm whales and
dolphins also use clicks for
communication. And inside of those clicks
is probably one of the most
sophisticated forms of communication
we've discovered on the planet. Could be
more sophisticated than human language.
Now I know that sounds completely nuts
to all of you. And certainly sounded nuts
to me when I first started researching
this stuff a couple of years ago. But
just consider a couple things.
The sperm whale brain is about six times the size
of ours. This is a picture of sperm whales
facing us head-on. And that top thing
is their nose and behind that is their
brain. Now sperm whales also have
a neocortex. In humans the neocortex
is believed to govern higher level
functions like conscious thought,
future planning, and language. Well sperm whales
not only have a neocortex, but theirs
is about six times the size of ours.
Sperm whales also have spindle cells.
These are long and highly developed
brain structures that neurologists
have associated with compassion, love,
suffering, and... you guessed it.. speech.
All of those things that make humans human.
And separate us from great apes. Well
sperm whales not only have spindle cells,
but have them in a far larger quantity than
we do. And they've had them for 15
million years longer than we have.